[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur le plateau
de face aux territoires sur tv5 monde
avec nos partenaires habituels ouest
france nice matin france antilles le
groupe la montagne et puis 20 minutes
qui nous accompagne donc tout le long de
cette émission avec un invité politique
aujourd'hui particulier qui est louis
giscard d'estaing bonjour bonjour j'ai
résilié être avec nous et giscard
d'estaing vous êtes président de la
fondation valéry giscard d'estaing vous
êtes vice président de l'udps et y on va
beaucoup parler politique évidemment et
législatives dans cette émission vous
êtes maire de chamalières succéder à
votre père qui est également maire de
chamalières quelques années vous êtes
vice-président de la de carmaux
métropole et vous êtes conseiller
régional d'auvergne rhône alpes emmanuel
mâcon vient d'être réélu par les
français valéry giscard d'estaing
appréciait-il emmanuel macron l'at-il
connu personnellement oui il a eu des
occasions de de le rencontrer et
évidemment je ne pourrais pas porter
gérer d'appréciation en son nom
je pense qu'on a parlé
lui l'occasion de changer bien sûr
puisque depuis l'élection des manuels
macron jusqu'à la disparition de mon
père que vous le savez celui ci était
encore parfaitement à même d'avoir un
regard sur la vie politique d'un certain
sus sur certains sujets je pense à
l'europe de continuer à s'exprimer et
donc il nous a fait part des
siens je ne crois pas qu'il pouvait
considérer comme enfin selon cette
expression comme un des siens je pense
qu'il qui considérait qu'il avait des
qualités importantes pour continuer à
mener des projets européens dans
l'esprit de ce que lui avait fait deux
français sur trois c'est le titre d'un
livre qui avait écrit votre père
emmanuel mâcon tente de réussir ce pari
on voit bien en gros 60% des français le
rejeter six mois avant l'élection
présidentielle il a été réélu avec 60 %
du corps électoral est ce que c'est un
rêve qu'on aurait voulu réaliser votre
père écoutez on ne peut pas comparer
deux élections très différente quand on
est élu au deuxième tour face à marine
le pen
ça m'oblige à faire un retour en arrière
en 1974 jean marie le pen était candidat
à l'élection présidentielle face à mon
père face à françois mitterrand vous le
rappeler il avait fait 0 75% des voix au
premier tour un autre pays oui un autre
pays je crains que l'élection de
françois mitterrand et la suite ont
propulsé le front national puis ensuite
le rassemblement national à ces niveaux
électoraux c'est louis giscard d'estaing
donc président de la fondation valéry
giscard d'estaing et vice-président du
des ics est notre invité politique ce
matin 10 mai 1981 arrivée au pouvoir
françois mitterrand 19 mai 1974 arrivée
au pouvoir de valéry giscard d'estaing
on en reparlera tout au long de cette
émission dans un instant françois-xavier
le franc de ouest france est notre
invité
[Musique]
françois-xavier lefranc bonjour merci
d'être avec nous louis giscard d'estaing
vice président de l'udps et y avait qu
une majorité présidentielle qui se
dessine exactement bonjour monsieur
giscard d'estaing vous êtes on
vice-président du délit l'union des
démocrates et indépendants créée il faut
le rappeler en 2012 par jean-louis
borloo alors il ya quelques
parlementaires de lui qui ont rejoint
emmanuel macron notamment en bretagne
par exemple vous n'avez pas été tenté de
rejoindre la majorité des manuels macron
alors d'abord merci de m'accueillir et
de me permettre de répondre
effectivement entendu ce président dudit
et je suis très heureux de pouvoir le
faire parce que c'est vrai que nos deux
formations politiques en décompte du csa
doit pas être
extrêmement haute dans les dents les
interventions donc très heureux de
pouvoir le faire alors s'ils voulaient
de notre position c'est que dans l'ue
des iae et d'indépendance donc pour nous
c'est le critère déterminant nous avons
déterminé notre position en conseil
national et à une très très large
majorité nous avons décidé de soutenir
au premier tour d'élection
présidentielle valérie pécresse cette
position n'était pas partagée par
l'ensemble de l'ue dit mais vous la
regretter un peu ou pas ah non ne nous
considérons que nous étions dans une
cohérence complète nous avons et si on
revient sur l'histoire de la vème
république je rappellerai que mon père
député jeunes députés indépendants et
paysans avec antoine pinay a fait partie
des premiers gouvernement du général de
gaulle sans être gaulliste dont kylie a
chez nous cette idée très claire que
nous souhaitons apporter une valeur
ajoutée dans les territoires on y
reviendra peut-être et aussi sur le plan
politique parce que nous ne sommes pas
dans la majorité présidentielle monsieur
à croquer ski fondamentalement sur le
plan des idées des valeurs vous sépare
des mâles une macro et de sa majorité on
va dire ce qui nous distingue plutôt que
ce qui nous sépare ce qui nous distingue
c'est nous considérons d'abord que
effectivement les territoires la
décentralisation une vision
décentralisée de la france ça doit
primer sur tout autre aspect ce qui
n'est pas tout à fait me semble-t-il est
nous semble-t-il la vision d' emmanuel
macron et et d'autre part que sur un
certain nombre de sujets
enfin nous avons des interrogations sur
la ligne politique poursuivie par un
gouvernement ou par le futur
gouvernement puisque donc pour l'instant
on est dans cette période transitoire
avec des profils ou des personnalités
venues de différents différents partis
de l'échiquier politique nous ce qu'on
souhaite c'est de la cohérence dans
l'action et et sur des sujets le pouvons
nous retrouver bien entendu alors vous
êtes on l'a dit un élu des territoires
vous êtes maire vous êtes élue régionale
dont vous connaissez particulièrement
bien les problématiques locales et vous
avez approché au plus près l'état
centralisé aux côtés de votre père le
président giscard d'estaing on entend
souvent des élus locaux en france dire
l'état est loin l'état ne nous fait pas
confiance l'état jacobin mépris ces
territoires et parfois les mots sont
très dures
vous en pensez quoi de de ça alors parce
qu'il y à des signaux qui n'ont pas été
très positifs envoyés ces dernières
années je pense je suis membre du comité
directeur de l'association des maires de
france où la mf et quand emmanuel macron
est venu en 2017 souvenez-vous devant le
congrès des maires de france en novembre
2017 et qu'il dit je reviendrai tous les
ans pour rendre compte de mon action et
que dès l'année suivante il ne vient
plus au congrès des maires donc là il ya
eu je crois un mauvais signal envoyé à
l'ensemble des élus locaux et cette
confiance a été également ébranlé par la
question de la réforme ou la suppression
de la taxe d'habitation qui est un sujet
sur lequel des formations politiques
comme le dit considère que finalement
c'est une réforme un peu en trompe
l'oeil puisque par définition il fallait
compenser le manque à gagner est par
ailleurs ça a creusé le déficit de
l'état qu'est ce que vous diriez au
président macron aujourd'hui vous le
maire en tant que maire maire de
chamalières qu'est ce que vous lui
diriez sur la tente des mères c'est quoi
la première chose à faire pour être
renforcée se lire de confiance qui est
évidemment essentiel fait alors je
prends un exemple tout simple la
question des préfets
dans le puy-de-dôme nous avons eu quatre
préfets différents depuis l'élection d'
emmanuel macron quatre préfets
différents alors j'espère que ce n'est
pas un cas dans tous les départements de
france mais ce que je demande par
exemple
c'est qu' il y ait un délai
incompressible
de deux ans minimum pour qu'un préfet
reste dans un département et qu'ils
aient le temps d'accompagner les devis
d'amendé un colonel prenant un régiment
il sait qu'il le prix il dirigera son
régiment pendant deux ans comment se
fait-il que dans un pays qui se veut un
pays exemplaire sur certains principes
de gestion de management enfin en tout
cas qui aspirent à ce niveau
d'excellence peut en arriver à une
situation aussi
contradictoires nous ce que nous voulons
page 2 nous les maires on veut des
interlocuteurs avec qui nous pouvons
échanger dans la durée qu'on ne dise pas
au bout de trois mois aux six mois vous
allez avoir un nouvel interlocuteur vous
êtes aussi je le rappelle l'élue
régionale et la région c'est finalement
un bol une bonne échelle pour pour
travailler l'économie au plus près des
préoccupations des citoyens
les régions n'ont pas tellement de
moyens aujourd'hui en france par action
comparé à d'autres régions européennes
par exemple le dise l'un des allemands
par exemple pour l'environnement
rappelle souvent que le la somme des
budgets des régions françaises c'est
c'est la catalogne c'est à peu près ça
comme si comme si l'état se disait faut
pas trop leur donner de pouvoirs on ne
sait pas trop ce qui se passerait
derrière
pourquoi qu'est ce qu'il faudrait faire
pensez vous qu'il faut une étape forte
de décentralisation précisément pour
permettre aux territoires dont vous êtes
le représentant
de voilà d'agir les doigts et plus
efficacement bien sûr très volontiers si
vous voulez parce que les régions y
compris les régions a grandi puisque là
aussi nous sommes passés par des
bouleversements
territoriaux de grande ampleur auvergne
rhône-alpes c'est urgent au passage
c'est une chose moi ce que je constate
simplement
quand monsieur hollande lance cette
réforme une réforme quand même majeurs
de dire aux habitants de poitiers qui
sont rattachés à la même région de saint
jean de luz et aux alsaciens qui vont
être avec le champagne ardenne et
lorraine ne s'est pas neutre de faire
des réformes comme ça sans engager au
minimum le congrès est à dire la réunion
de l'assemblée nationale et du sénat et
une majorité des trois cinquièmes ça
serait le minimum pour faire des
réformes dont on voit aujourd'hui les
conséquences alors après les régions
nous nous avons effectivement nous
viendrons nabeul nous avons une grande
région par cette fusion néanmoins les
moyens ne sont pas supérieurs à ce
qu'ils étaient auparavant mais ce qu'il
faut pas justement une vaste réforme qui
permettrait de donner plus de moyens
parce que est-ce que c'est pas à partir
des territoires convainc peu retisser
certains murs qui sont communes à
décrisper la france par les territoires
mais comme vous le voudrez faire l'ours
polaire mais si vous voulez je crains
malheureusement que le contexte on va
voir j'ai bien sûr j'attends et
j'observe ce qui va se passer dans les
prochaines semaines mais si vous voulez
les signaux ou tel qu'ils peuvent avoir
été envoyée même pendant la campagne la
courte campagne présidentielle de
monsieur macron ne sont pas extrêmement
encourageants en termes de réforme
territoriale ou de moyens nouveaux
donner aux territoires louis giscard
d'estaing est notre invité il est vice
président de l'udps et ich au nuc et
dessinateur et collaborateurs de
ouest-france régulier à une question à
vous poser sous forme de dessin c'est la
tradition de cette émission on écoute on
regarde chaunu
bonjour en cette semaine où l'on a
célébré l'europe quelque chose me dit
que de là haut le président valéry
giscard d'estaing et son vieux complice
de toujours
le chancelier helmut schmidt ont dû
suivre avec le plus grand intérêt la
rencontre entre emmanuel macron et olaf
scholz les deux hommes écrivant d'une
nouvelle page de l'histoire du couple
franco allemand mais revenons à des
choses plus terre à terre oui très
emmanuel macron est aussi un joueur
d'accordéon il espère avoir une large
majorité qui s'étire de la droite à la
gauche mais une fois le souffle et les
élections retombées bien la france
risque de connaître une période
volcaniques alors permettez moi de vous
poser deux questions très différentes
l'une de l'autre la première la droite
et le centre est elle une force
d'opposition ou sera t-elle absorbé par
la macro ni et la deuxième question
porte sur le bras de fer qui oppose
laurent wauquiez le président de la
région auvergne rhône-alpes au maire
écologiste de grenoble eric piolle
êtes-vous pour ou contre le port du
burkini dans les piscines municipales
vous êtes très concerné car vous êtes
conseiller régional nouvelles on doit
d'une part que nous avons une très belle
piscine à chamalières piscine olympique
donc alors pour la première pour la
première question qui concernait donc le
d'après moi c'était sur le dit oui alors
le petit livre pour le bloquer mais je
réponds tout simplement bien sûr il ne
faut pas autoriser le burqini dans les
piscines séparées une cata mauvaises
décisions et merci droite centre et
alors que sa cote à hollywood bien sûr
la question de l'union de la droite et
du centre quelques constituent
effectivement l'alliance pour les
législatives entrer l'air élus dei ça
correspond à un axe d'alternative pas
d'opposition nous avons besoin dans
notre pays d'avoir une alternative
crédible qui se situe au centre droit et
à la droite de la majorité
présidentielle telle qu'elle se dégage
voilà c'est pas une opposition c'est une
alternative françoise et le franc ça
veut dire que demain on pourrait
imaginer que lui dit rejoignent
peut-être la majorité n'ont pas pour s'y
fondre mais pour apporter son regard
qu'on est guéri mais ça veut dire aussi
qu'il faut dans ce cas là à voir une
vraie une vraie négociation fin des ça
se fait dans tous les pays démocratiques
parlementaires du monde actuellement le
problème des manuels macron c'est qu'il
ne traite pas que les partis politiques
il traite avec les charger dans les
salles j'espère parce que je considère
que c'est enfin une démocratie
parlementaire c'est des coalitions vous
avez raison de le dire en allemagne
c'est donc aux éditions qui se négocie
sur la base programmatique la une
d'ouest france françois xavier de francs
alors la une d'ouest france est
évidemment en référence à la guerre en
ukraine les la pénurie de blé et la
crainte d'une crise alimentaire qui peut
peut-être d'ailleurs amener les
européens à s'intéresser d'un peu plus
près à leur agriculture parce que ça
c'est un vrai défi françois-xavier
l'offrant rédacteur en chef du plus
grand quotidien francophone du monde
merci d'avoir été avec nous ce matin
dans un instant denis carot de nice
matin sur ce plateau
[Musique]
aujourd'hui car vous êtes le directeur
des rédactions du groupe nice matin où
un instant nous allons comme interviewer
louis giscard d'estaing notre invité ce
matin en face aux territoires sur
tv5monde en direct mais tout de suite
nous nous rendons dans le puy de dôme
vous connaissez bien ce département
louis giscard d'estaing vous en êtes
l'élu fils l'alose que vous connaissez
également qui est directeur éditorial du
puy de dôme pour la montagne le groupe
centre france la montagne notre
partenaire à une question à vous poser
depuis clermont-ferrand vous connaissez
bien si louis giscard d'estaing votre
père qui était un partisan d'une
troisième voie entre une europe
supranationale et une europe des états a
proposé dès qu'il a été président de la
république en 1974 la mise en place du
conseil européen lundi dernier emmanuel
macron a affirmé sa volonté de réviser
les traités de l'union européenne vous
qui êtes président de la fondation
valéry giscard d'estaing dont le but est
de faire connaître la période de
l'histoire politique économique et
sociale de la france et de l'europe
durant laquelle veilleux a joué un rôle
important que pensez vous de cette
volonté de réformer l'europe mais cette
volonté de réformer l'europe elle
s'inscrit finalement d'une certaine
façon dans ce que mon père lui-même
avait identifié comme étant les
problèmes de l'europe c'est-à-dire le
fait que l'élargissement avaient précédé
les réformes institutionnelles ce qui
était évidemment le la mauvaise séquence
et vous souvenez qu'il avait été chargé
par jacques chirac lionel jospin dans la
cohabitation de présider une convention
pour la réforme des institutions
européennes qui a abouti à un certain
nombre de préconisations qui ont
finalement été transposée dans le traité
de lisbonne mais ils considéraient
qu'effectivement il restait un certain
nombre de réformes à mener pour bien
faire fonctionner mieux faire
fonctionner l'europe lundi carottes wild
card est un emmanuel macron a plaidé
lundi pour une europe plus plus
puissante on voit clairement qu'il veut
prendre le leadership qu'il s'appuie
pour cela sur la sur la présidence
européenne sur la présidence française
est-ce qu'il a la bonne approche alors
oui mais ça ne surprendra pas ceux non
de mois donc oui il a raison d'eux de
dire qu'il faut reprendre un certain
nombre de chantiers sur la réforme des
institutions européennes pour la faire
mieux et pour faire mieux fonctionner
l'europe pour sur certains sujets ne pas
être tenus par là la règle de
l'unanimité mais mais il faut pouvoir
pour canton
je dirais quand on a vocation à
entraîner derrière soi d'autres pays
européens eh bien il faut donner le bon
exemple et et je pense notamment dans
ses relations dans le couple franco
allemand il faut donner le bon exemple
sur la gestion des finances publiques
sur la capacité de réformer un pays qui
accumule les déficits qui accumule la
dette depuis l'élection de françois
mitterrand rappelle que notre dette a
explosé elles étaient pratiquement les
thèmes que de 20% du du pib' en 1981
elle est maintenant à 120% du pipe donc
on voit bien que nous avons de ce point
de vue là nous n'avons pas donne envoyer
les meilleurs signaux à nos partenaires
et en particulier les allemands vous
tout à l'heure vous évoquez le couple
franco-allemand constitué par mon père
et le chancelier helmut schmidt il avait
été ministre des finances dans leur pays
respectif avant de venir en situation de
responsabilité et et de créer l'euro sur
la base d'une convergence des économies
et en tout cas des parités de change
entre le franc et le deutsche mark il y
a trois ans au moment du lancement de la
campagne des européennes vous avez
estimé en reprenant une phrase célèbre
de votre père que emmanuel macron n'a
pas le monopole de l'europe est ce que
vous diriez la même chose aujourd'hui
enfin bien sûr au sens où personne entre
guillemets n'a le monopole de l'europe
et qu'il ne faut pas justement dans un
esprit de pédagogie vis-à-vis de nos
partenaires européens il ne faut pas
s'ériger en étant une sorte de
deux champions ou deux héros de de
l'europe si ce n'est comme comme
capacité d'entraînement et souhait
qu'une fois quand je reviens à toutes
les avancées majeures qui ont été
réalisés quand ton père était président
la république française est en liaison
avec le sang se lier le match mi temps
en allemagne c'était dans le cadre d'une
entente mais une entente s'appuyant sur
des convictions partagées et ensuite la
convergence de leurs leur analyse vous
le disiez tout à l'heure votre père a eu
jusqu'à la fin un regard aiguisé sur la
vie politique
est-ce qu'il avait des des regrets
concernant l'évolution de l'europe et et
lesquelles oui il avait des regrets il
les a exprimés dans un livre qui
s'appelle europa qui est qui est un
livre qu'il a publié en 2014 et qui
effectivement indiqué qu'il souhaitait
des cercles vous savez de des cercles
différents pour les projets européens ce
qui en réalité déjà le cas avec l'euro
puisque tous les pays ne sont pas dans
la zone euro tous les pays d'europe et
sur ce schengen notamment où
effectivement là aussi ce sont des
accords qui ne sont pas
globale sur l'ensemble de l'union
européenne mais surtout vient de tomber
louis giscard d'estaing la finlande est
favorable à une adhésion sans délai à
l'union européenne non à l'otan pardon
excusez
la finlande et et déjà de longue date
dans l'union européenne mais c'est vrai
que ça va bouger les lignes ça peut
bouger les lignes ou pas alors c'est
toute la question de l'articulation sur
la défense européenne entre entre
l'union européenne et l'otan certains
pays traditionnellement préfère le
produit le bouclier qui assure l'otan
pour leur défense et leur sécurité
extérieure notamment vis-à-vis du bloc
de l'est parce que il est vrai que
monsieur poutine par son attitude a
réussi à ressusciter l'otan souvenez
vous la phrase emmanuel macron l'otan et
en mort cérébrale il y a un an de bon
maintenant de la finlande de la hausse
et souhaite rejoindre le temps donc on
voit bien sans délai et donc on voit
bien que ceci a fait bouger les lignes
par contre sur la défense européenne
il faut effectivement renforcer la
défense de l'union européenne qui est
autre chose que le temps le 2 décembre
dernier le parlement européen rendu
hommage à votre père un an après sa
disparition
ce moment est important oui je porte
d'ailleurs la cravate que m'a offerte ce